ก็
สวัสดีค่ะพี่เอ๋
สวัสดีค่ะค่ะครูเรียมสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียน
สวัสดีค่ะนักเรียน
ครูเรียมคะวันนี้
วันนี้วันอะไรคะ
วันนี้วันอาทิตย์ค่ะขอ
โทษค่ะ
วันนี้วันอาทิตย์นะคะ
วันอาทิตย์
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 8
วันที่ 8 เดือนอะไรคะเดือน
พฤษภาคมเดือน
พฤษภาคมปีค.ศต้ดคะผช
2022 ค่ะทีมผชเท่าไหร่คะข้อ 2500
4  15 รักเอานี้เวลากี่โมงคะ
ตอนนี้
13:00 น 24 นาที
ตอนนี้บ่ายโมง 24 นาทีนะคะ
คุณผู้หญิงคะ
อีกหรอ
อุ้ยพ.ศ.แล้วถึง
ข้อ 2
ขอโทษค่ะ
2565 นะคะผชคู่เตรียมคะครูเห็นข้างหลัง
ของครูเรียมเนี่ย
เอ่อ
ไม่ไม่เหมือนเดิมกูเรียนอยู่ที่ไหนคะ
เนี่ยตอนนี้เตรียมอยู่ที่อุดรค่ะ
อยู่ที่ on นะคะตอนที่จังหวัดเออ
ใช่กู ah มีรูปนี่นักเรียน
วันนี้ครูเรียมอยู่ที่จังหวัด
ดอนจะค่ะสวัสดีดอกดีหาสำนักทุเรียนมอง
เห็นไหมคะถ้ามองเห็นคุณลืมวงได้
อุดรอยู่ตรงไหนคะครูเรียม
อยู่ตรงนี้ค่ะ
ดีมากหน้า
เดี๋ยวๆบ้านครูเรียมอยู่ที่ไหนนะคะ
บ้านของเรียนอยู่มหาสารคาม
ตรงไหนคะอ๋อ
มหาสารคามอ้าแต่ตอนนี้ครูผู้เตรียมไป
จังหวัดอุดรธานี
ใช่แล้วอุดรอุดรที่นี่
กูเลียมคูเรียมไปที่นี่หรอคะที่อุดถ้า
ไม่ใช่ค่ะเดี๋ยวลบให้
กูเอกก็พยายามลบ
กูเดี๋ยวไม่ได้ไปที่นี่นะคะ
ที่ไหนตัวเอง
อันนี้อันนี้ชื่อชื่อเกาะคำชะโนด
ที่นี่นะคะนักเรียน
และมีเป็นหนองน้ำ
หนองน้ำคูเรียมอยู่อุดรแล้วคุณเรียมต้อง
ไปที่คำชะโนด
เคยไปไหมคะไม่เคยไปค่ะ
เลี้ยงต้องไปอันนี้มีมีชื่อเสียงคะนัก
เรียนคอนไปมากๆไปแล้วก็ไปไหว้
ไว้เกาะคำชะโนด
ทำไมต้องไหว้ค่ะ
ได้ยินใช่มั้ยได้ยินมั้ยทำไมจะไปไหว้อะไร
เคยได้ยินเคยได้ยินอยู่นิดหน่อยเกี่ยวกับ
พญานาค
[เพลง]
ได้เกี่ยวกับพญานาคกับกูอ่ะที่คำชะโนด
เนี่ยมีมีรูปปั้นพญานาคแบบนี้นะคะนัก
เรียนครับเมื่อกี้หมดแล้วทำไมต้องไปไหว้
ใช่ไหมใช่คือที่หาดที่พริกเกาะคำชะโนดนภู
เรียมก็จะมีต้นไม้ต้นแบบนี้ค่ะเรียกว่า
ต้นชะโนดนะ
ต้นชะโนดแต่ที่สนุกกว่านั้นก็คืออันนี้
ค่ะ
คือเกาะเนี่ยเป็นเกาะที่เมื่อก่อนน่ะน้ำ
ไม่ท่วม
อาโคเรียนรู้จักเกาะภูเก็ตใช่ไหมคะรู้จัก
ค่ะรู้จักเกาะภูเก็ตและเกาะนะคะนักเรียน
อ่ะต่อกับเดะมีเกาะอามิเกาะนะๆเกาะอันนี้
น้ำน้ำทะเล Stick เกาะภูเก็ตเกาะสมุยรู้
จักนะสมุยสมุยเวลาฝนตกเราเวลาเกาะเนี่ย
เวลาฝนตกอีกคลื่นน้ำก็จะท่วมจะไปคะ
น้ำจะท่วมเกาะ
และเกาะภูเก็ตเกาะสมุยนะอยู่ที่ทะเลนะคะ
ทะเล
โคเอนลบตรงนี้ก่อนแต่ว่าอุดรอุดรมีทะเล
ด้วยหรอคะทำไมมีเกราะ
อุดรไม่มีทะเลนะคะอันนี้อันนี้ก็ภูเก็ต
เนอะเดี๋ยวกลับเลยนะคะตอบภูเก็ตเกาะสมุย
อยู่ที่ชเลนะคะช้างอยู่ตรงนี้อันนี้เกาะ
ช้าง
อุดรจังหวัด
ดูกรอุเนี่ยไม่มีทะเล
แตมป์เกาะ
มีเกาะเกาะอยู่ในหนองน้ำค่ะตรงนี้หาเป็น
หนองน้ำ
ไปหนองน้ำนะคะ
อันนี้อันนี้กอใช่ไหมคะร้านเป็นหนองน้ำ
หนองน้ำใหญ่ใหญ่มาก
นะเราก็มีเกาะอยู่ข้างในหนองน้ำคู่ได้
เห็นในคะเนี่ยเห็นค่ะแต่ว่าคุณเอ๋บอกว่า
เกาะนี้เป็นเกาะที่เวลาฝนตกเวลาน้ำเยอะๆ
ก็จะไม่จมหรอคะได้คือปกติถ้าเราคิดถึง
เกาะใช่ไหมคะแล้วอยู่ในหนองน้ำถ้าฝนตกน้ำ
มาน้ำมาน้ำท่วม
บริเวณตรงนี้ค่ะครัวนะคะเนาะเกาะก็เนี้ย
อาจจะน้ำท่วม
จากน้ำท่วมที่นี่และเกาะเนี่ยน้ำไม่ท่วม
เมื่อก่อนนะมาต้นมาก่อนอ่ะคนก็เลยไปไหว้
เพราะเกาะเนี่ยถ้า
ค่าน้ำค่าน้ำแบบนี้ค่ะสวรรค์เกาะที่นี่
ให้กรอบเป็นสีเขียวหรอก็เป็นสีเขียว
อะน้ำอยู่ตรงนี้เกาะก็อยู่ตรงนี้ถ้าน้ำ
ขึ้นมาตรงนี้
ก็ขึ้นมาอยู่ตรงนี้
ทน้ำหนักน้ำลงมาที่นี่
เกาะลงมาที่นี่
น้ำไม่ท่วมเกาะ
สมัยก่อนนะไปก่อนอ๋อรักถ้าพี่พูดเองได้ก็
สมัยก่อนแต่ว่าให้ตอนนี้ตีตอนนี้บาย 13
ขวบม
คูเรียมสงสัยไหมทำไมน้ำไม่ท่วม
สงสัยค่ะทำไมน้ำไม่มีค่ะเตรียมออกเพราะ
ว่าเกาะนี้นะเป็นเกาะที่ลอยน้ำ
เกาะที่ลอยน้ำ
ที่จะมีต้นไม้นักเรียนค้ามีต้นไม้ต้น
เนี้ยค่ะที่เรียกว่าต้นเขาชะโนดแล้วครู
เรียมต้นไม้ที่ปกติต้นไม้เนี่ยต้นไม้เค้า
จะมีราดร่างยาวๆถ้านี้ใช่ไหมร้านเก่ายาว
แต่ว่า
เขาไม่มีร่างอันนี้จะเข้ามีร่างเล็กๆ
รักเล็กๆ
เรียกรักฝอยตัวนี้รักแก้วละเต็มแก้วดัก
ไม่มีมีแต่รากฝอยรากฝอยเขาก็เป็นสะอาดกัน
เหมือนแพรวเหมือนเรือเลยค่ะที่ครูเรียน
เห็นในรูปเนี่ยค่ะนะคะ
นะครับเห็นไหมคะตรงนี้
ร้านค้าแบบนี้เขาก็จะรอลอยน้ำรอยขึ้นรอย
ลงลอยขึ้นลอยลงแต่อันนี้ไม่ใช้แน่น้ำ
เมื่อไม่ใช่แม่น้ำเขาก็เลยไม่ลอยออกไป
แต่ก็จะมีรอยขึ้นร้อยลง
สะพานเนี่ยทำไปก็เมื่อก่อนทำก็หักค่ะก็
ต้องมีเทคนิคทำแตกถ่ายก็
ออกไม่รู้คิดว่าโห
มหัศจรรย์เกาะไม่จมน้ำรอยขึ้นลอยลงแล้ว
เขาก็มีมีมีความเชื่อเขาเรียกว่าเรื่องละ
เรื่องเล่าเกี่ยวกับเกาะนี้มีเรื่องเล่า
ให้อะไรคะ
จริงๆมี 2 เรื่อง 3 เรื่องเลยนะคะครู
เรียมแต่วันนี้เอาเรื่องที่ที่ที่คนไทยไป
แล้วที่คุณเรียนบอกทำไมว่าไอ้ก่อนที่ครู
เรียมแปลว่ามีมีพญานาคใช่ไหมล่ะมี
เรียกว่าพญานาค
พญานาคที่เกาะเนี่ยก็มีพญานาคสีเขียว
นี้สีกูอีกสีเขียวไหม
สีเขียวนักเรียนสีเขียวกับนี้
เกี่ยวไหมสีเขียวเขียว
และอัดเขียวนะคะแล้วก็นักเรียนดูตรงนี้
ตรงนี้ก็สีเขียวอันนี้ก็จะออกเขียวๆเนาะ
อ่ะแต่ก่อนจะเล่าเรื่องเนี่ยกูเอกจะพากู
เรียนไปรู้จักป่ะ
พญานาคในเรื่องเนี้ยนะคะเป็นเป็นความ
เชื่อเกี่ยวกับเกาะนี้นะคะพญานาคก็จะมีมี
เป็นเรื่องของเมื่อก่อนจะมีพญานาคอยู่
222 จะมีนาดแล้วก็พญานาคพญานาคเนี่ยควร
อ้าน่าจะลูกน้อง
เอ๊ะหน้าคุ้นเล็กๆคุยขยายคนเรียนก่อนนะคะ
แล้วที่อยู่ในรูปนี้เป็นขยะนาคหรือว่า
เป็นหน้า
อ่าเป็นพญานาคกับโพเรียม
มีสองพญานาค 2  2 ตน
2 พญานาคบางคนก็เรียกองค์สองตนเองเป็น
เพื่อนกัน
มันกี่ผู้ 2 ตัวก็ได้เป็นเพื่อนกันแล้ว
เป็นอ่ะเราเป็นเพื่อนกันเพื่อนมันคู่
เตรียมคู่เอ๋เป็นเพื่อนกันไหม
เพื่อกันนะคะเพื่อนกัน
มีพญานาคสีเขียวแล้วก็พญานาคสีเหลืองคอม
มีชื่อด้วยกูเรียม
พญานาคสีเขียวชื่ออะไรอ่าชื่อเท้า
ศรีสุทโธ
แล้วค่ะอย่านั่งสีเหลืองนะคะ
สีอื่นจริงสีเหลืองหรือสิ่งทอง
เหลืองทอง
ปิดทอง
ขอโทษค่ะพญานาคสีทองตัวสีทอง
สุวรรณนาคราช
[เพลง]
สุวรรณคือทองนะคะอันเนี้ยสีทองแล้วก็สี
เขียวสีเขียวน่ะเท้าศรีสุทโธแล้วสีทอง
ชื่อสุวรรณนาคราชนะคะถ้างั้นนักเรียนก็จะ
รู้จักแล้วนะ 2 พญานาค
2222 แรก 2 ซอยที่ 2 ตัว 2 คน
ob
โอเคมีเท้าสีสุดแล้วก็สุวะอัคราชนะคะเขา
ศรีสุทโธกลับสุวรรณนคราชอ่ะเลยนักเรียน
รู้จักก่อนนะคะพญานาคในเรื่องนี้ก็จะมี
เท้าศรีสุทโธแล้วก็สุวรรณนาคราชนะคะ
ขอโทษนะบัญชีกูเอร์ก็ไม่รู้เรียกแล้วก็มี
ช้างมีช้างราคาตัวนี้อะไรคะคุณเรียม
เล่นใช่ไหมหาให้ค่ะแม่เรียมแม่นเนี่ยใหญ่
กว่าช้างใช่ไหมไม่ใช่ห่าเล่นตัวนี้กว่า
ช้างอะช้างแต่ในหมอช้างเล็กเน้นใหญ่
ออปโปเอทำผิดใช่ไหมของเม้นท์ต้องเล็กใช่
ไหมคะ
เอาแม่นเล็กช้างไหนโอเคนะ
แต่กูเรียมขนทางและมีขนใช่มั้ย
ใช่คนชาติใหญ่หรือเล็กค่ะขนช้างเล็กค่ะคน
ช้างเล็กใช่ไหมคะคนแม่นราคาขนเม่นใหญ่
คนค้างกับขนเม่นขนอะไรอีกใหญ่กว่าฝนแม่น
ใหญ่กว่าขนชายกว่าโอเคนะคะอ่ะคนเม้นท์
ใหญ่กว่านะคะโอเคในเรื่องนี้ก็มีมีเท้า
ศรีสุทโธมีสุวรรณนาคราช
มีช้างมีแม่
แล้วก็มีใครคะคะก
ไก่พระอ่านพระเห็นไงและอิ่ม
สั้นๆนะสั้นๆชื่อพระอินทร์นะฮะให้ in ตัว
สีอะไรขา
สีเขียวค่ะห้าสีเขียวนะคะนี้สีเขียวอ่ะ
นักเรียนคะที่คำชะโนดนะคะที่เกาะเกาะ
คำชะโนดเขามีเรื่องมีความเชื่อแบบนี้ครู
เรียมนี่เรากลับมาที่นี่นะคะเขามีความ
เชื่อว่ามีเว็บอาจเป็นเรื่องเล่าเป็น
เรื่องที่บอกว่าที่คำชะโนดเป็นที่อยู่ของ
ที่อยู่เป็นประตูประตูมันบ้านบ้านก็ต้อง
มีประตูใช่ไหมคะ
เป็นประตูประตูนสีขาวสีสุทโธนะจะขึ้นมา
นะก็ทาสีสุดโทขึ้นมากี้เกี่ยวอะไรกับสวน
นคราช
ให้ค่ะ
ค่ะยิ้มเขาแต่ว่าเดี๋ยวถามใจเธอเข้าใจว่า
ถ้าศรีสุทโธกับสุวรรณนคราชอยู่บนเกาะด้วย
กัน
[เพลง]
ไม่ใช่ไม่ใช่ไม่ได้หยุดวันก่อนด้วยกันอ่า
ตรงเนี้ย
หนองน้ำเนี่ยหนองหนาวอันนี้เกาะไหมคะเกาะ
หนองน้ำเนี้ย
หนองน้ำที่เนี่ยเป็นหนองน้ำใหญ่
มากอ่ะเมื่อก่อนที่นี่แหละว่าหนองแส
หนองแสแล้วก็จะแบ่งครึ่ง
แบ่งครึ่งว่าครึ่งและ
เป็นที่อยู่ของ
ท้าวศรีสุทโธอีกครึ่งหนึ่งเป็นที่อยู่ของ
อ่ะอะสุวรรณนคราชนะคะ
เขาก็เชื่อว่าตรงนี้ตรงคำชะโนดเนี่ยค่ะ
เชื่อว่าพญานาคน่าจะอยู่ใต้น้ำ
อยู่ข้างล่างที่นี่ใช่ไหมคะที่นี่ก็จะ
เป็นที่อยู่ของ The  Copy มาดีกว่าแม่
โอเคโอเคมาว่าตรงนี้เนาะ
ทำไปอานาคเล็กๆ
อันนี้พญานาค
เต็มที่หนองน้ำที่นี่เนี่ยกักโอเรียม
ที่หนองน้ำน้องก็จะแบ่งครึ่ง
แต่งเพลงไปก็เราจะอยู่กันคนละครึ่งเป็น
เพื่อนกันข้างบนอ่ะเอามาไว้ข้างล่างเนาะ
อ่ะอยู่ใต้น้ำ
ข้างบนก็จะมีมีอะไรนะอาจจะมีอเมริกาเกาะ
คำชะโนดเนี่ยค่ะแล้วก็ใต้น้ำใต้น้ำก็จะ
เป็น
เป็นวังใช่ไหมเป็นวัง
เป็นวังของอ่ะ
เป็นวางของสุวรรณนคราชกับฐานศรีสุทโธแล้ว
หนองน้ำตรงนี้ค่ะน้องแสนอ่ะจะมีอาหาร
สมบูรณ์แต่ว่าใครหน้า 2 ตัวเป็นเพื่อนกัน
นะครับเป็นเพื่อนรักกันมาก่อนแต่ก็มีลูก
น้อง
กะเท้าศรีสุทโธก็จะมีลูกน้อง
ลูกน้องเนี่ยเราเรียกว่าหน้า
หน้าควรอ้าเนี่ยพญานาค
ส่วน
ตาสุวรรณนะคะและก็มีลูกน้องเหมือนกัน
[เพลง]
สองก็มีลูกน้องเยอะเหมือนกันกูเองกูเอง
ว่ารูปมันเลข 2 เลยใช่ไหม
ที่นี้เนี่ยปรากฏว่า
อ่ะลูกน้องอ่ะคือสองคนเป็นเพื่อนกันค่ะกู
เหลี่ยมแต่รูปน้องเนี่ยเวลาตื่นกันไม่ชอบ
กัน
ลูกน้องก็อยากจะคิด
หัวหน้าชั้นแข็งแรงที่สุด
ใช่มั้ยหัวน่านฉันมีอำนาจที่สุดคือเวลาจะ
กินอาหารนะคะพญานาคก็จะออกไปแล้วก็ไปหา
อาหารกินข้างนอกก็ลูกน้องก็จะออกคะตัวเอง
บอกว่าพญานาค 2 ตนแบ่งพื้นที่กันแล้วแล้ว
จะติดเจอกันยังไงคะอ่ะอยู่ข้างล่างอ่ะ
แบ่งกันแต่บัญชีพักขึ้นไปข้างบนน่ะค่ะ
แต่งทั้งบทไปหากินพญานาคทั้งสองพญานาค 2
อัดเท้าศรีสุทโธไม่ได้ขึ้นไปเอง
ใครน้าสุวัณณะขนาดก็อาจจะไม่ได้ขึ้นไปเอง
แต่ลูกน้องลูกน้องเนี่ยขึ้นไปเวลาขึ้นไป
หาอาหารบัญชีเจอกันเพราะว่าไม่ได้มีไม่
ได้ดีกำแพงได้บอกไหมไม่ได้มีกำแพงบอกว่า
เครื่องนี้ของฉันนะคะพรุ่งนี้ของเธอนะไม่
ได้มีกำแพงอันนั้นบางทีลูกน้องก็ไปเจอกัน
ก็ทะเลาะกัน
เอาลูกน้องทะเลาะกันลูกน้องทะเลาะกันควร
อ้าใช่มั้ยพญานาค 2 ตัวปวดหัวมั้ยปวดหัว
ค่ะหยุดคิดว่าปวดหัว
เพราะว่า 2 ตัวเป็นเพื่อนกันเป็นเพื่อน
กันโอ๊ยลูกน้องทะเลาะกันก็ปวดหัวก็เลย
ตกลงทำสัญญากัน
โอเคนะ
จำกัดยาวัดไม่ให้ลูกน้องทะเลาะกันเนี่ยก็
คิดว่ามันไปคนละวัน
สมมติว่าวันนี้วันนี้วันอาทิตย์อ่ะสมมุติ
นะคะสมมติวันอาทิตย์ทีมของท้าวศรีสุทโธ
ขึ้นก็ไปหาอาหารได้อาหารมาก็แบ่งครึ่งให้
กับ
ทีมของสุวรรณนาคราช
รักครึ่งนึงนะคะพรุ่งนี้ทีมสุวรรณนะคะ
ร้านไปได้อาหารอาก็แบ่งครึ่งให้กีบเท้า
ศรีสุทโธงั้นเนี่ย 2 ลูกน้องสองทีมไม่
ต้องเจอกันไม่ทะเลาะกันดีไหมคะพี่อีก
หนึ่งก็คิดว่าโอเคเรื่องก็จบใช่ไหมคะ
เปลี่ยนถ้าหัวหน้ากับหัวหน้าตกลงกันสบาย
ไม่ทะเลาะกันแต่ไม่จบแค่นั้นน่ะสิครู
เตรียม
มันมีเหตุค่ะวันหนึ่งวันหนึ่งปากเท้า
ศรีสุทโธเนี่ยคืนไปแล้วก็
คุยกับเตี้ยนี้ก่อนขึ้นไปแล้วก็ไป
ไปเจอทาง
ไปเจอช้างมหาขึ้นไปข้างบนเราก็ไป
เจอช้างก็จับช้างมาเป็นอาหารแล้วก็แบ่ง
ครึ่งนึงไปให้ส่วนนะคะราด
ไปให้แล้วก็เอามีขนช้างในไปให้ดูด้วยก็จะ
มีครึ่งนึงก็คือมีหัวครึ่งเลยหนูคือ 1
ไม่ใช่ครึ่งหน้าครึ่งหลังขึ้นแบบนี้เลย
อ่ะสุวรรณนาคราชก็เห็นใช่ไหมคะเนี่ยมีขน
แล้วก็ได้ครึ่งหนึ่ง
โอเค
ก็ช้างตัวใหญ่ใช่ไหมคะก็ขอบคุณก็ทีมของ
สุวรรณนคราชก็กิน
ก็ไม่เป็นไรวันรุ่งขึ้น
สุวรรณนคราชก็ขึ้นไปไปเจอ
เม่น
แม่น
วันนั้นไม่มีสัตว์ไปครูเรียมไม่มีสัตว์
เลยมีแต่แม่น
แล้วเป็นเงินน่ากลัวเนาะเล่นก็ตัวเล็กๆ
ใช่ไหมค่ะ
แม่นตัวเล็กหรือตัวใหญ่คนเดียวเนี่ยอ่า
ส่วนเลข
ที่เล่นใหญ่หรอได้ตัวเลขนะ
เล็กมากใช่ไหม
แม่นช้างอยู่ช้างใหญ่กว่าเม้นเยอะ
หลังใหญ่มากนะฮะเน้นนี้ต้องกับผิวเลย
ถ้าแม่นอยู่กับช้าง
แม่นนะจะประมาณนี้เนาะชาวอันนี้คือใหญ่ไป
นะแม่จะเล็กกว่านี้อีกนะ
แม่เล่นกับช้างอยู่ด้วยกันไม่เจอเล็กมาก
นะคะอยากคุยอยากให้นักเรียนเห็นมันใหญ่ๆ
โอเคนี่
โอเคไม่ใหญ่นะ
จริงๆเล่นเล็กๆนะคะแต่วันนั้นน่ะกูเรียม
ไม่มีอาหารเลยก็ได้แม่นมา 1 ตัว R พี่สุ
วันนะคะละก็เป็นเพื่อนดีเอาสุวรรณะนะคะ
เป็น
หน้าที่ใจเกม
ใจดีเรียบร้อยนะคะส่วนนะคะราดก็เลยอ่ะ
แบ่งเม่นให้เพื่อนอ่ะครึ่งนึง
นะคือจัดการคือเวลาก็แบ่งเธอก็ผ่านเค้า
ชอบแหล่ะนะคะเขาได้ต้องชำแหละ
ๆกินข้าวก็จะเอาหนังออกใช้เวลาจะแบ่งเขา
ก็จะเอาหนังออกเอาออกทั้งหมดก่อนแล้วก็
แบ่งครึ่งให้นี่ก็เหมือนกันเขาก็จะเอา
หนังออกแล้วก็แบ่งครึ่งนะแม่นอ่ะไปให้กับ
อ่ะให้กับเท้าศรีสุทโธครึ่งหนึ่ง
โอเคไหม
ก็แบ่งไปปุ๊บเนี่ยอ่ะคือต้องบอกก่อนว่า
Top ศรีสุทโธกับสุวรรณนคราชแต่บางทีก็
อาจจะไม่ต้องกินอาหารนะคะอันนี้แบ่งให้
ลูกน้องลูกน้อง
ปรากฏว่าลูกน้องเท้าศรีสุทโธก็เห็น
ค่ะวันนี้แม่นอ่ะขนใหญ่มากขนนะใหญ่ทำไมมี
เนื้อนิดหน่อย
กินไม่อิ่ม
เห้ยเมื่อวานใช่ไหมคะค้างช้างแรกขนเล็กๆ
แล้วตัวขนาดนี้เราก็แบ่งช้างให้ไปครึ่ง
นึงแต่วันนี้เนี่ยไอ้เนี่ยขนใหญ่
ทำไมเข้าแบ่งให้เรานิดหน่อย
งั้นเนี่ยลูกน้องของท้าวศรีสุทโธตัวคูณ
เลียมก็อดคิดว่ากลุ่มของสุวรรณนาคราชอ่า
เนี่ย
ขี้โกง
ไม่ได้แบ่งครึ่งนึงก็ไปหาท้าวศรีสุทโธ
แล้วก็บอกว่าเท้าศรีสุทโธ
หน้าของสุวรรณนคราชน่ะแบ่งเนื้อสัตว์มา
นิดหน่อยไม่ใช่ครึ่งนึงเท้าศรีสุทโธก็ถาม
ทำไมเนี่ย
ตอนนี้ไงมีมีขนใหญ่มาก
ขนใหญ่ก็แปลว่าตัวเนี้ยตัวใหญ่ใช่ไหม
เพราะช้างเนี่ยคนเล็กชนะตัวขนาดนี้
อันเนี้ยขนใหญ่มากตัวต้องขนาดนี้สิ
ทำไมให้เรานิดหน่อยเตรียมลึกว่าลืมนึกออก
แล้วว่าลูกน้องหรือว่าหน้าที่ที่เป็นลูก
น้องของท้าวศรีสุทโธคือยังไม่รู้ใช่ไหม
อ่ะก็ไม่รู้จักเน้นฝั่งรูปลูกน้องของสวน
นคราชจับตัวอะไรมา
ๆคือเขาไม่รู้จักเน้นเขาไม่รู้จักแม่น
แล้วเขาเห็นแค่ขน
ขนวันใหญ่ตัวมันต้องใหญ่ใช่ไหมคนเนี๊ยะ
ตัวเท่านี้คนที่เนี่ยตัวเท่านี้ทำไม
แบ่งแบ่งนิดหน่อย
ก็ไปฟ้องฟ้องอ่ะเท้าศีรษะโตคือพญานาคและ
เขาก็จะนั่งสมาธิเขาไม่กินเนื้อสัตว์ได้
แต่ลูกน้องอ่ะลูกน้องต้องกินเนื้อสับนะคะ
อ่าเท้าศรีสุทโธก็เลยมาหาส่วนนะคะราด
น้ำมหาสุวรรณนคราชแล้วก็ถามว่าทำไม
คุยกันแต่ก็มีป่ะ
ทำไม
ทำไมไม่แบ่งครึ่งทำไมไม่แบ่งครึ่งทำไมมี
อาหารไปให้ลูกน้องชั้นนิดหน่อยอะนิดเท้า
ศรีสุทโธนะอะ
เท้าศรีสุโทเนี่ย
ขอโทษครับใครไปไหนนะสีเขียวคู๋หายไปไหน
ขาวศรีสุทโธนะคะเท้าศรีสุทโธไปหาสุวรรณ
นคราชแล้วก็ถามทำไมให้เนื้อนิดหน่อย
สุวรรณนะเราก็โกรธมากๆออกโหลดด้วย
จำผิดรู้สึกว่า
โกรธถ้าภาษีถูกโกรธก่อนนะแล้วก็เข้ามัย
สุวรรณนะคะละก็รู้ก็เลยอธิบายบอกว่าไม่
ใช่นะให้เครื่องนึงจริงๆแต่วันนี้ไม่มี
อาหารสัตว์มันตัวรอง
เท้าศรีสุทโธก็บอกเลขอะไรขนใหญ่
แต่ว่าน่ารักทุกตัวกินเม็ดหมดแล้วไงเรา
ไม่มีเหลือให้ดูใช่ไหมคะขาวศรีสุทโธทาง
ฝากเท้า 46 ไม่เชื่อค่ะครูเลี่ยม
โกรธไม่เชื่อเพื่อนแล้วจะรู้ได้ยังไงคะใน
เมื่อทุกคนถูกจริงๆเข้าไปหมดแล้ว
ลูกน้องก็บดขี้โกงบอกไม่ได้โกงทำไมทำไมใจ
ดำคือสุวรรณนะคะละก็พยายามอธิบายว่าไม่
ได้โกงนะไม่ได้เอาอะไรไม่ได้โกงไม่ได้เอา
ไว้เยอะๆรักให้หน่อยอ่าแต่ว่าฝั่งท้าว
ศรีสุทโธก็ไม่เชื่อก็เลยเกิด
อะไรขึ้นสงครามสู้แบบตู้มา
ดูกันนาน 7 ปี
ตี
ใกล้สู้ไปโอกายเป็นวาดเวลานาคพญานาคสู้
กันเนี่ยนานก็มีอื้ออื้อนา5ปลาก็ตายสัตว์
ก็ตายต้นไม้ก็พังนะจน
ถึงพระอินทร์กินรู้หน้าพระอินทร์รู้นะไม่
เห็นก็โกรธมาก
พระอินทร์กันเลยอ่ะทำยังไงดีคะอินนะทัก
คะเองก็มา
กูอ่ะลบตรงนี้ก่อนนะคะ
ช้างพระอินทร์
พระอินทร์ไปไหน
เป็น
พระอินทร์ต่อไปอีกนะคะอ่ะเย็นก็มา
ออกไปเม้นท์ออกไป
พระอินทร์ก็บอกว่าหยุด
สองทีมก็พูดไม่ฟังใช่มั้ยเท้าศรีสุทโธก็
ไม่ฟังก็โกรธก็สู้กันอ่ะกับพระอินทร์ก็
บอกเอาอย่างนี้
หยุด
in จะให้อาหารเอง
ให้อาหารก็คิดว่าอาบให้หน้า 2 ตัวทำแม่
น้ำ
อายุทำแม่น้ำจากจากตรงนี้นะค่ะจากตัวนี้
ราะ
จากตรงนี้เป็นหนองแสนอ่ะ
หนอง stat ให้ทำแม่น้ำไปและทะเลนักเรียน
รู้จักทะเลน้อ
ทะเลแต่สีฟ้าใช่ไหม
ทะเล
ทะเลให้ทำแม่น้ำให้ไปถึงทะเลท่าพญานาคตัว
ไหนทำแม่น้ำถึงทะเลเสร็จก่อนจะให้ปลาระทำ
แม่น้ำสมมติว่าว่าเป็นแม่นะครับที่นี่
แม่น้ำจะให้ปลาราคาจะให้ปลา
กัดตัวใหญ่ๆชื่อระบึกอยู่ในแม่น้ำจะได้
กินอิ่มบ๊าย
5r แล้วก็แบ่งครึ่งนะแบ่งครึ่งแล้วพระ
อินทร์ก็บอกว่าโอเคตรงนี้จะมีพูห์เต๋า
ภูเขาไฟ
ที่ถูก
ห้าม
อีกตัวหนึ่งยุ่งนะหมายความว่าเอ่อไปคนละ
ทาง
ไปคนละทางคนละแม่น้ำไม่ใช่แม่น้ำใกล้ๆกัน
คนละทางก็ปรากฏว่ามีภูเขาไฟที่นี่ใช่ไหม
คะเท้าศรีสุทโธก็ออกมาที่นี่สุวรรณนคราช
ก็มาที่นี่
สาวศรีสุทโธออกมาไปทางตะวันออกมาคุยให้ดู
กันพี่
ซื้อเอกคุยกับเตี้ยนี่มาละกันนี่อะประเทศ
ไทย
มาที่ประเทศไทยนะคะ
ข้าวศรีสุทโธ 3 4จุดโทรมาทางนี้
ทางนี้
เราก็
สุวรรณนะคะนาดค่ะบุรินทร์อ่ะเอาไปทำอะไร
คะอะไรนะคะ
ส่วนนะคะรัฐไปทางไหนคะ
จะวันนาคราชอาหารที่สุวรรณนคราชเล็กๆเนาะ
I ทางนี้ค่ะ
คนละทางนะคะแล้วก็ภูเขาอยู่ตรงนี้อ่ะภู
เขาดงพญาไฟอยู่ตรงไหนอ่ะแถวนี้ใช่ไหม
แถวนี้แหละ
เท่านี้เป็นผู้เขาฟังไปร้อนๆแล้วก็พญานาค
ทั้งสองทีมก็ทำแม่น้ำโคเรียมทำแม่น้ำ
ก็อยากรู้เขาว่าใครคิดทำแน่น้ำเสร็จเป็น
คนแรก
โค้ชเอ๋ใช้สิทธิ์ต้มละกันเน๊าะ
ตอนนี้ค่ะอ่ะนางสาวศรีสุทโธเป็นพญานาคใจ
ร้อน
ก็ทำแม่น้ำไม่ล่ะ
เกิด
คือทำแม่น้ำคือที่บอกว่าใจร้อนคือเพราะ
มุดดินอะแม่น้ำเจอภูเขาหลบเจอก้อนหินหลบ
ไปเอง
หลบก็ทำให้แม่น้ำโค้งโค้งไปโค้งมานะคะได้
เร็วไม่ต้องทำอะไรถูกเขาหน้าส่วนสุวรรณ
นคราชมาตรงนี้ก็ทำแม่น้ำจากจากจังหวัด
น่านเนาะ
หน้า
ทำมาอ่านเจอภูเขาก็โอเคค่อยๆไปนะไปๆไปทำ
ดีๆก็ทำแม่น้ำจากที่นี่มาส์ก
ก็
จะดึง
งั้นเนี่ย
สุวรรณนะคะราดค่ะแม่น้ำน่าน
แนะนำนานค่อนข้างจะตรงค่อนข้างเดียวตรง
แต่เท้าที่สุดโททำแม่น้ำโขงแม่น้ำโขงก็จะ
คงไปโครงมาใช่มะอันเนี้ย
โค้งสายของขวาของศาลแต่ว่า
ข้าวศรีสุทโธทำเร็วกว่าคุณเตรียม
ศรีสุทโธฉัน
ทำแม่น้ำมาจนถึงทะเลเป็นคนแรก
แล้วก็ยาวแล้วก็ถึงทะเลเพราะทำเร็วแต่ว่า
ไม่สวย
อ่ะไม่ตรงไม่ตรงแม่น้ำโค้งก็ทำเร็วก็เลย
ได้มะนาบึกในป่าตัวใหญ่ๆ
อยู่
ในแม่น้ำโขงนะคะแต่ที่นี้เนี่ย
ปรากฏแล้วก็ต้องแบ่งครึ่งใช่มั้ยแบ่ง
ครึ่งไปละ
แบ่งครึ่ง
แบ่งครึ่งไปอาบสุวรรณนาคราชก็ต้องไปทาง
นี้ไปทางเหนือภาคเหนือของไทยอ่ะเท้า
ศรีสุทโธก็ทางอีสานกูเรียนจะสังเกตทาง
อีสานพญานาคสีเขียวเนาะทางเหนือพญานาคสี
ทองก็ไปทางนี้อ๊อฟใช่ไหมถ้ากูเอกสงสัยไม่
นานทำไมคนนั้นสิหนีพ่อไปทางนี้ปุ๊บเนี่ย
ก็ต้องกลับไปอยู่วังหน้าใช่ไหมคะ
เราก็
อยากจะขึ้นมาบนโลกทำยังไงก็ขอพระอินทร์
พระอินทร์พระอินทร์อยู่ไหนอ่ะพระอินทร์
พระอินทร์
พระอินทร์นะคะอ่ะพี่ก็เลยขอพระอินทร์ว่า
อุ้ยขอโทษค่ะ
อ่ะยินอีกนะคะค่ะยินเล็กๆ
ก็บอกให้ in ว่าขอ
ขอที่เนี่ยเป็นประตูสำหรับขึ้นมาที่โลกใน
ไหม
เพราะว่าน่าจะอยู่ที่โลกนานๆก็ไม่ได้ต้อง
กลับได้น้ำจะกลับแล้วเนี่ยก็จะต้องขึ้นมา
ข้างบนใช่ไหมคะก็เลยขอเป็นประตูเขาก็เลย
บอกว่าพระอินทร์ก็โอเคงั้นเนี่ยตรงนี้
แหละพี่คำชะโนดเนี่ยก็จะมีบ่อน้ำ
บ่อน้ำนะคะก็คืออันนี้ค่ะ
เป็นบ่อน้ำนะคะให้เป็นบ่อน้ำแต่จะมีบ่อ
น้ำข้างในก็จริงนะคะสำหรับอ่ะเท้า
ศรีสุทโธขึ้นมาหา
คนธนูนเขาก็มีเรื่องเล่าแบบนี้วัดที่
เนี่ยเป็นประตูสำหรับเท้าศรีสุทโธขึ้นมา
หาเขามีความชื่อแล้วแบบนั้นแล้วก็จะไป
ไหว้สำหรับโชคดีแต่สำหรับคนที่ซื้อกะนาง
พญานาคค่ะน้องสุวรรณ์นคราชไม่ได้ขึ้นมา
จากบ่อน้ำตรงนี้ไปได้ไม่ได้อันนี้ของท้าว
ศรีสุทโธส่วนนะคะราชสุวรรณนะคะนะครับมี
ประตูค่ะหนูนาความนายกมีหนึ่งที่
คลิปนักทุกตัวจะมีประตูประตูเป็นบ่อน้ำ
ขึ้นมานะเนี่ยบ่อน้ำบ่อนะที่น้ำน้ำสวยๆ
น้ำตลอดปีนะเขาบอกเป็นบ่อของภยันนาด
อาทิตย์อ่ะ
จะมีฝนเข้าไปไหว้
ได้แล้วพอมีคนไหว้ปุ๊ปเนี่ยเขาก็สร้างรูป
ปั้นพญานาคสร้างศาลา
ปางอะไรก็เลยทักให้เกราะน่ะน่ะเวลาน้ำมา
ก็เลยรอยไม่ได้ก็เลยจงน้ำ
ตอนนี้ห้ามแล้วทางสร้างห้ามออกอะไรไปวาง
เพราะเกาะน่ะ
นะคะเป็นธรรมชาติแบบนี้
100% เนี่ยตอบจะลอยขึ้นลอยลงได้
ตอนนี้เขาอยากให้เข้าไปได้นะ
อ้า
ก็ต้องดูว่าเอ๊ย
คนว่ายได้แต่ต้องกี่คนเพราะว่าถ้าคนเข้า
ไปเยอะๆก็น่าจะน่ากลัวนะคุยกลัวจะจมน้ำ
เออกูลืมอย่างไปว่ายในค่ะ
ไปไหว้จะโชคดีนะธุรกิจดิ๊ร้านกายแข็งแรง
เอกไปเอกเคยไป
กลัว
เอกกลัวผู้ฟัง Story อีกเรื่องนึงว่าแล้ว
คุยครัว
ตัวเอกกูเองไม่ไม่ไปไหว้พญานาคขึ้นคือคือ
โอเคอ่ะโอเคค่ะแข็งแรงพญานาคมีอำนาจแต่
คู๋เอกกลัวนิดหน่อยก็ยังไม่ไปกลัวเกาะจม
น้ำใช่
เอกกลัวเกาะจมน้ำผมไม่ไปนะคะ
บอกว่ามี Story เรื่องนึงเก็บก็เลยอยาก
เล่าให้ฟังสั่งหน้าได้ไหมค่ะอาทิตย์หน้า
อาทิตย์หน้า
ค่ะวันนี้ตื่นเต้น
นักเรียนออกหวัง
เกี่ยวกับคำชะโนดเหมือนกันค่ะมีเรื่อง
เรื่องที่ครูเอกจำได้มี 2 เรื่องนะคะ
เดี๋ยวอาทิตย์หน้าจะมาเล่าหมดแล้วค่ะเลย
แล้ว
คลิปนี้กูเอกกับครูเรียมก่อนนะคะผู้เรียน
อยู่อุดรไปเลยค่ะรัวนะ
ไม่รู้กูเอกคนชลบุรีอ่ะค่ะกูเอกก็เลยกลัว
กูเรียมคนมหาสารคามอุดรโอเคพญานาคกับคน
อุดรคนมหาสารคามโอเคไอ้คิดนะ
แต่ก็เอกกูเองกูเองอยู่บ้านตัวเองไม่เอา
กูเอกตัวพญานะเอา
ไม่รู้
มีกันอยู่ติดต่อคำหน้าได้ค่ะแล้วเข้ากัน
ไว้ที่หน้านะคะวันนี้นักเรียนนี้ก็รู้
แล้วนะคะว่าอ่ะที่เที่ยวที่หนึ่งที่คนไทย
ชอบไปก็คือเกาะคำชะโนดเป็นประตูของพญานาค
อ่านคนไทยไปว่ายนักเรียนอาจจะเคยไปเอง
แหละเย้ทำไมคนไทยไหว้แล้วมาจากไหนอ่ะรัก
วันนี้ก็เข้าใจแล้วว่าเท้าศรีสุทโธนะคะ
เป็นใครมาจากไหนนะคะโอเคค่ะลูกว่าค่ะ
ขอบคุณพี่เอมากค่ะ
มีครับอ่า
[เพลง]